organs were doing a lot of work with
virtual currencies and virtual economies
right now because so many of the games
we do our online and are working on
social networks and are working off of
microtransactions and you end up having
to think about these things and it's
it's a very curious space it's a space
that we're all kind of finding our way
in and kind of learning learning how it
works there's some basic things that we
we certainly know i mean the a lot of
people assume that oh i'll create some
kind of virtual economy and like people
will spend money on it but that's
certainly not true what you have to do
is you have to create a situation where
people are going to want to put money in
so you have to find a way that people
are going to feel invested and if you
look at the way a lot of the successful
online games are created particularly
the free ones they create a situation
where they work hard to get you
psychologically invested and then they
they find exactly the appropriate time
to kind of say you know this game could
be a little better if you would just put
five bucks in or you would just put ten
dollars in or maybe they'll even mask it
if you would just contribute you know
eight facebook credits that kind of
thing then you could suddenly get this
make this better so it's it's okay and
we're not used to this as game designers
game designers are used to we're going
to make the best game possible and we're
going to want people to know about it
because they're going to pay upfront and
then we're going to deliver a game that
they think is great we don't have to
think about that anymore but now it's
like we're all designing you know the
point of purchase display at walmart
right and we're trying to figure out
what how do we position the racks of gum
that's going to make people buy more
than one pack of gum you know and that's
that ends up being how you have to think
about it so very often now one of the
big changes is we design games around a
psychological moment where people are
willing to spend money and we figure
well how do we kind of make that moment
is exciting and engaging as possible
it's we're not used to that we're used
to kind of having fun be at the core but
now fund
is at the core and we have to kind of
build out that way which is which is
very different
what's going to happen with virtual
currencies is is is interesting I mean
because the advertising folks just like
everybody else are really kind of trying
to struggle to figure out what is this
new digital media mean an interactive
advertising is problematic right because
when you say here's an advertisement now
you can interact with it your first
interaction is make it go away right
because you don't want advertising
that's the whole point of advertising is
you don't want it and so advertisers are
going to realize the incredible power
that the the ways they can tap into
these virtual economies as we become
more and more connected right now people
think that these virtual economies they
think of them that they're isolated and
that they're off somewhere but
everyone's going to start to realize
that it's just you know information on
the internet and if you want to give me
a hundred gold if I buy a 24-pack of
coca-cola at the grocery store you could
do that now there's like no
technological barrier to keep you from
doing that the grocery store already has
a unique bar code that you swipe when
you exit they already know your email
address most likely all you have to do
is give them one more piece of
information about your world of warcraft
account and bang you can start doing
that right there and the same goes for
you know farmville in any game that has
an online virtual currency and the
advertisers are going to start to see
that wow these currencies mean something
to people they put people put in hours
and hours of their lives trying to build
up this currency how can we have them
engage with our brand purchase our
products spread the word about our new
products you know give reviews to our
products etc etc and reward them with
these virtual currencies we're starting
to see it happen already on Facebook
we've seen quite a bit of this and I
think we're going to see it kind of
branching out into the real world quite
a lot there they're starting get the
idea they're trying to figure out how to
begin there's kind of a priming the pump
problem that they have right now but all
is going to take is a couple successes
in this space and you're going to see
just a huge just an ocean of like of
experiments and some of them are
going to succeed